>> BOYD: So I definitely encourage you to
all attend the GTAC happy hour. The GTAC is
a great set of organizations that promote
Google technology around the world but, you
know, more importantly they all get together
and talk about things that they love. They
talk about the various technologies and how
they're moving forward. And so go to the happy
hour but then also go to the next GTAC meeting
and meet up with the folks and talk about
the things that you like and things that you
don't like that Google is doing and we can
all make the world a better place. So my name
is Ryan Boyd. I'm a developer advocate at
Google. And I'm here today to talk about OpenID
and OAuth at Google. So I'm primarily a developer
advocate on Google Apps, so you'll see a little
Google Apps slant here. But in general, I
want to talk about how these technologies
are used across Google. Actually, you can
see my Twitter handle there. If you have any
follow up questions or critique, feel free
to give me an app reply on Twitter. So today,
we're going to talk about an overview of the
different terms that are involved with OpenID
and OAuth. We're going to talk about each
of those protocols. Then we're going to talk
about the hybrid combination of the two. And
then I'm going to go through a practical example
of an application that's been around for a
while and show how it's evolved through these
different protocols. So OpenID and OAuth and
this whole space around identity and the access
authorization for data is rapidly moving.
Things keep on changing and there's a lot
of work going on there. So I'm not going to
be diving deep into the protocols. I'm going
to be showing you some of that but not too
much. What I want you to understand when you
leave today is really the different protocols
that exist, what the used cases are for them
and how they can apply to your application
to create a better experience for our users
and thus get more users. So what we're talking
about? The first term we're talking about
here is authentication. The idea behind authentication
is determining who you are, determining the
actor that's making requests. So with OpenID,
this is determining who it is that's browsing
the website. But in generic terms, authentication
is used for other purposes as well to identify
applications and that sort of thing. And then
we're talking about authorization. What can
you do? So after we've determined who the
actor is, we need to determine what permissions
that actor has to access what resources and
perform what actions. So for authentication,
we're going to primarily be talking about
OpenID. For authorization, we're going to
be primarily talking about OAuth. If you treat
these terms very strictly, they really merge
together and clash in a number of places but
we'll trying not to do that in this introductory
presentation. So, OpenID. OpenID is about
federated identity. And I want to give you
an example of OpenID before I actually dive
into more information about the protocol.
So I'm going to go over here. We're going
to go over to a website that I love; it's
called Tungle. How many of you have heard
of Tungle? All right, just a few. I wasn't
sure how popular it was outside of Silicon
Valley. But, basically, Tungle is an online
scheduling application. What it does is allows
you to share your schedule with the world
and allow your customers or partners to create
appointments on your calendar at the times
that you make available. So, one of the things
that Tungle does is really tries to get you
into the application quite easily. So you
can here at the bottom of their sign in page,
they allow you to do the typical first name,
last name, email address and password, but
they also allow you to sign in using one of
your existing accounts. So I'm going to click
in an icon here. And although I can't read
this, I'm still going to approve it. It's
basically asking me to just pass my information,
my name, my email address and my Portuguese
language over to this application. So I'm
going to hit "permit."
And the application is going to log me in
and immediately go into a very simple set
up process. It already knows who I am. When
I return to this website, as long as I log
in with my Google account again, it will again
know who I am securely and that makes it a
lot easier. No longer do you have to receive
email confirmations, create password, deal
with password resets; you can use the one
account that you're used to using for a lot
of different sites or at least any site that
implements OpenID. So now, we're going to
hop back to the presentation and we're going
to talk about the different parties involved
with OpenID and federated identity. The first
party we'll talk about is the user. That's
like me. It's someone who's trying to login
to a web application. The identity provider
is the place on the web where I have my account;
the place on the web that I want to validate
that I am me. This is oftentimes email providers.
You can create your own, but oftentimes it's
email providers for most users as you just
saw on this application where I logged in
with my Google account or my Gmail account.
And then there's the relying party. In the
demo that I just gave, the relying party was
Tungle. It's a web application which wants
to allow users to use their existing identity
to login into their application. So here's
what some of this may look like. I'm calling
federated identity here. There's a little
bit of controversy with this model. In this
model, we have three applications down the
center. Those applications are SaaSy Payroll,
which is a fake online payroll application
which we're going to use later in the demos;
TripIt, which is an online travel planning
service; and Aviary, which is an image editor.
Each of these applications allow me to login
via OpenID. SaaSy Payroll just allows me to
login with my Google account. TripIt and Aviary,
however, could allow me to login with either
my Google account or my Yahoo account. Some
may call this directed identity instead of
federated identity because these applications
are restricting what identity providers I
can use to login rather allowing me to use
any place on the web. But in this case, there's
still multiple identity providers and multiple
relying parties. OpenID is a safe, faster
and easier way to log into websites. As you've
heard all of this terminology, you're probably
not thinking it's easier but it is. It's easier
for our users and we're going to talk about
each of these terms. This is kind of the model
that's used on the OpenID website and here's
how--what these different terms mean to me.
Safe. Because the users only enter in their
credentials in one place, they're only trained
to provide their password to one site. Fishing.
They're going to be much less susceptible
to fishing attacks and that sort of thing
because they know that they're only going
to enter in their credentials at their identity
provider. It's faster. The user is already
often logged in to their OpenID provider.
In the case that I demoed--I don't remember
actually whether I was logged in or not--but
I'm often logged into my Gmail on a regular
basis. So if I go to login to a website, I
don't even have to type my password. All I
have to do is tell that website, "It's okay
to pass my identity onto the website." And
easier. The user no longer needs to create
and maintain a different set of credentials
on a bunch of different websites. Now, in
practice, most people don't actually maintain
a different set of credentials. They use the
same password everywhere which gets back to
the "safe" idea. Though there is some--there's
actually--our network technician here yesterday
was wearing a T-shirt that said, "OpenID.
Now you only need to steal my password once."
But you may only need to steal a password
once but there are things that are being done
to make those identity providers a lot more
secure. Google--for Google Apps recently announced
what is called true factor authorization.
So it requires you to have your cell phone
available and you receive a text message or
an SMS message in order to log on to the website.
So you provide your password plus that text
message. So you're approving multiple things.
You can greatly secure each of these individual
identity providers a lot easier than you can
secure every website that wants to rely on.
So there is a discovery challenge though.
You want to determine the OpenID provider
of the user. As we saw with some of the previous
examples, I was just saying, "Use Yahoo or
use Google," but, you know, the initial version
of OpenID was very open. And what it meant
is that you could actually type in any URL
here. You could basically say, "My OpenID
provider is at www.google.com/account/oa."
Only geeks actually use this, only geeks could
remember what the URL was and only geeks cared
about this. So OpenID wasn't that popular.
There wasn't much adoption. But the community
embraced a different way of doing OpenID and
this is what we call the OpenID NASCAR. What
this means is that the websites or the relying
parties present a bunch of different logos
for you. They tell you, "You can log in using
your Google account or Yahoo account or your
Twitter account." And you click on one of
these buttons, it then allows you to log in.
This is a much better way to interact with
users but it actually gets at a problem that
OpenID was created to prevent. It basically
makes it--if you don't have a popular OpenID
provider, if you don't have an OpenID provider
that everyone's going to include on these
NASCAR batch pages, then you can't sign in
to the website. You have to do--create a new
user name and create a new password. So this
is what I'd like the future to be where you
enter in your email address and you can log
on to the site. It discovers who your provider
is and you can immediately login. We're getting
there. You may have noticed that there is
a Google Apps button and a regular Google
button. Google Apps actually gets partially
the way there to that ideal world where you
click Google Apps and you can actually type
in your domain name. And there's a little
bit special magic sauce here, but Google Apps
will issue OpenID identities on your actual
domain. So there's this two different formats
of OpenIDs. We have the Google Consumer accounts
which you gave a Gmail account. This is what
the OpenID looks like. And OpenID identity
is really just a URI. And you can see here's
a URI for a Gmail account. And then for a
Google Apps account, the OpenID identities
are on their own domain. This makes it a lot
easier if you wanted to, say, move off of
Google Apps. I don't know why you'd want to,
but if you did want to move off of Google
Apps, you can take your OpenID identity space
with you. So Google supports a number of different
extensions for OpenID. We're going to talk
about the hybrid extension later as we mentioned.
I'll also talk a little bit about the attribute
exchange here. By default, OpenID provides
just that URI. It just says, "This is a unique
identifier that will be returned to your application
every time this user logs in," so you can
maintain state across the user's login. You
know who the user is but you don't know information
like their name or their email address. Attribute
exchange provides that information and it
makes it a lot easier to provide a good user
experience for the user. So we support a number
of different extensions. You can read up on
them online. But the biggest point that I
want to stress here with OpenID, there is
that safe, faster, easier--it's not only safe,
faster and easier for users, but it's also
better for web application developers because
you don't need to deal with storing passwords,
you don't need to deal with securing your
stored passwords and you can also get users
into your website a lot faster. And this means
in the end you'll have more users. So how
is this done? Well, there's all this complicated
terminology. It may sound complicated but
it's not really hard in practice because a
number of different libraries have been written
that handle OpenID authentication. These libraries
have been written by people and have been
reviewed by plenty of people and used by plenty
of people, so they're much more likely to
be secure than any code you would write yourself.
I would strongly urge you not to write your
OpenID code by hand, not to write your OAuth
code by hand. It's tricky and there are people
that have done it before you. So take advantage
of that. All of these libraries will do Vanilla
OpenID and some of them also handle Google
Apps accounts. So now we've talked about identity.
We've talked about how to figure out who that
actor is, who the person is that is logging
into the web application. But you want to
know more than just who the person is; you
also want to be able to integrate with their
data. You want to be able to integrate with
things like their calendar. Maybe you're a
video mashup and you want to integrate with
things like YouTube. Well, that's what OAuth
Authorized Data Access is about. So in terminology,
there's a protected resource. These are things
like your calendar, your YouTube videos. And
these protected resources reside on a server
at Google. They require authorization to access
or at least to be able to edit at times. Some
things are read-only avail publicly. But to
edit them, you'll need to have access. And
then there's the resource owner. The resource
owner is the person or entity that owns a
protected resource. They have the ability
and the rights to grant access to that resource.
Another couple of terms we're going to talk
about here is the client. In the case of the
SaaSy Payroll, online payroll application
I'll be talking about, it's a relying party.
In OpenID terms, in the OAuth terms here,
it's the client. It's the one that's making
HTTP request to the server, in this case Google
Calendar, to access data. Fairly simple terms
that you're probably already familiar with
some of them. So the different Google servers
that have protected resources, I actually
just listed eight of them on this slide, but
there's actually even many more APIs than
this. Google is really standing strong behind
OAuth and strong behind OpenID as the standards
that provide authorization and identity access.
So most of our APIs are accessible by OAuth
now and there's a lot of different cool data.
If you're into finance, you can get a user
stock portfolio. If you're into videos, like
I said, you can use YouTube, but then there's
all sorts of business applications as well.
There are a couple of more terms with OAuth
that I'd like to talk about. There's key management.
So the client needs to establish trust with
the server. In order to do that, the client
registers with the server. You're going to
be seeing that shortly. And then there's access
control. The server needs to decide when it
receives a request from the client, whether
it is going to grant access based off of the
grants that had been given to that client.
So let's talk about each of these steps. Step
one, the developer registers the client. That's
the key management. Step two, the resource
owner, oftentimes a user, grants access to
their data. That's access control. And then
the client application actually does access
the resource. In the registration step--I'm
not going to talk about all of this, but basically
there's a website that you go to to register
your application. Google has one for applications
using Google Consumer Accounts. The Google
Apps Marketplace, if you were here at that
talk, has a special place that it gives you
registration information. And then other companies
each have this as well. So there's an example
of the URL for Twitter to register your client.
Here's what the webpage looks like for where
the Google consumer sort of registration process.
And I'm registering--this is that Saasy Payroll
application. So I'm going in and I'm logged
in as myself as the developer, I should say
here, and I prove that I own the saasyapp.com.
There's a little bit of verification process
that goes on there, either via DNS or via,
you know, editing a file on your web server
to prove that you own it. And then Google
will issue a consumer key to you and a consumer
secret. These consumer keys and secrets are
basically used in OAuth to identify the client
and then also for the client to prove its
identity. The client has to be able to sign
cryptographically the request to prove its
identity. So you basically--you register your
app, you describe the name of your app and
you get an OAuth consumer key and secret.
We also support RSA stuff, but I'm not going
to get into that in this presentation. But
if you prefer using RSA instead of what's
called HMAC, you can do that. So, we've now
registered the client. So the client has registered
to the server, the server knows who the client
is. This is something you do when you start
developing your application. You then need
to have the resource owner grant access to
the resources. Keep in mind, the resource
owner may not be an individual end-user. It's
basically the person who is authorized to
grant access to those resources. And in the
case of a company, it may actually be the
company that is authorized to grant access.
So your work email, you might not have the
rights to be able to give an application access
to your work email or your work calendar.
Your company has to do that. And so, we have
two different types of OAuth that we'll talk
about for those two different cases. So for
the consumer where the individual user is
the resource owner, we use what's called three-legged
OAuth. Three-legged OAuth is actually the
standard version of OAuth. If you see OAuth
out there, they're likely referring to this.
And what that means is that there is a series
of web redirects where when the application
needs to access the user's data, it redirects
the user over to Google or over to Twitter
or another provider and says, "This application
is trying to access this data. Do you, as
a user, approve granting access to the data?"
In this case, I am--oops. In this case, I
am the resource owner and I'm at a company
called Smart Law Firm and the client is saasyapp.com.
It's the payroll application that we keep
referring to and the protected resource is
Google Calendar. I can choose either to grant
or deny access to that resource here. Now,
in the case of a business where the company
actually owns the resource, they might want
to be able to grant access to the SaaSy Payroll
application for all of their user's calendars
in one step. For this, they can use two-legged
OAuth. And the real difference here is that
the IT administrator goes into their Google
Apps control panel and actually says, "This
client, saasyapp.com, needs access to this
scope," and that's a URL representing the
Calendar API. And they can authorize it on
behalf of all their users. That way when the
individual user needs to have their Calendar
data integrated with the payroll application,
they don't need to grant access and they don't
need to understand if they have the rights
to grant access. They don't need to know if
their security policies allow them to grant
access because the administrator can do it
for them. So there are a couple of different
required elements when you're accessing a
resource using OAuth. There's the consumer
key and the consumer secret, which you already
saw. You saw we--those were issued to our
application at the time that we registered
it. Those consumer key--the consumer key is
used to identify the application. The signature
is created using the consumer secret and it's
used to prove that identity. And we'll show
you an example of what that looks like here
shortly. So when actually accessing the resources,
the three-legged OAuth flow where the user
is individually approving access requires
an additional perimeter called an OAuth Token.
That token indicates that the permission that
was granted by the user. So it says that this
application, SaaSy Payroll, has a right to
access this user, Ryan's, Google Calendar.
So that's presented from the client to the
server along with the rest of the request.
In two-legged OAuth, however, because the
access has been granted in advance by the
administrator, they will access the storage
server-side. So all the client needs to do
is identify itself and prove its identity
using that consumer key and consumer secret
in signing everything. And then, it needs
to say on whose behalf it is acting. So it
is acting on behalf of a particular user within
the organization. So in this case, it was
acting on behalf of, let's say, ryan@smart-lawfirm.com.
So it basically adds an additional query perimeters
saying who it's acting on behalf. And as long
as the domain administrator has granted that
access in advance, the client will be able
to access that data. So here's what this looks
like in an actual HTTP request. Just like
with OpenID, there are libraries that do this
for you, but I just thought you might want
to see the HTTP request to see if you can
understand what's going on here. So there's
various things done in cryptography and that's
timestamp to ensure that this request isn't
made again. And then there's also the signature,
which is generated. So this is what it looks
like. There are a couple of different types
of tokens with the three-legged OAuth scenario.
So with the scenario where individual user
is granting access by that website authorized
denying. There are a couple different of types
of tokens. Basically, the application creates
a request token. It gets an authorized by
the user and then exchanges that for what's
called an Access Token. And I'm gonna show
this to you. I don't expect you to remember
all of this. But there's an OAuth Playground
that's a really helpful tool for learning
some of this. It was actually written by another
Googler here named Eric Bidelman. If you've
seen him, thank him. It's a really awesome
tool. So what it allows you to do is go to
the top here and you say, "I am looking for
access to a particular API." So I want to
access to the contacts API. Click there. This
generates what's called a scope, which is
what data--my application is trying to access.
And then down here, you can see there's an
OAuth consumer key. We don't see a secret
because the client in this case is actually
this web application, it's the OAuth Playground.
So it has previously registered and gone on
a secret and that's stored on its server.
So there's this three-step process here. I
need to do--get a request token. So when I
do that, it basically performs an HTTP request
to the server and the server returns a request
token. It might be a little small, but I definitely
encourage you to play around with it yourself.
And then the next step is authorizing the
request token. So it authorized. And that
does the redirect for me. And just the same,
I can't understand Portuguese on this page
either, but it does ask me here to grant access
to my Google contacts. I recognize the words
a little bit. And I will grant access. And
then, the application can exchange my request
token for an access token now. And now, it
has everything it needs to make request to
an API. So what we're going to do here is
actually retrieve my contacts. So once this
is set up, you can access that API. And you
can actually access multiple APIs at once.
You can request access for calendar in YouTube
all at one time. But I put the URL in here
is this is kind of the URL to the rest of
API that I'm looking to get access to contacts,
and I hit execute. And let me do a little
syntax highlighting here. And you can actually
see--this says--the title of this feed is
Ryan Boyd's contacts. It retrieved all that
information based off of this authorization
header. Specify the OAuth consumer key and
then the signature and pass that to the server;
the server validated it. All right. So we've
talked about getting access to the user's
identity, knowing who the user is. We've talked
about getting access to their data, figuring
out, you know, what their contacts are, what
their calendar is or what their YouTube videos
are. But we've been in multiple steps so far.
You've seen me grant access to my identity,
so to pass on my email address; then you've
seen me separately grant access to my contacts
or my calendar. Well, we really want to be
able to do this all at once. And so, there
is an OpenID in OAuth hybrid process which
combined these two types of requests, and
it's a very simple three-step process again.
The developer registers the client just like
it did with OAuth. The resource owner grants
access to the data and access to the identity.
It all happens in one step. And then the client
application accesses the resource. It actually--it
actually occurs using a very similar process
to OpenID except as a result of OpenID, it
returns an OAuth token. I don't dive into
those details, but rest assured, this makes
it a lot easier for users and makes it a last
step--last steps in the process. And you'll
see this later with the SaaSy Payroll application.
So here is where as a user, I'm granting access
to both my identity, my name, and my email
address, as well as my Google Calendar in
one step. All right, so when do you use each
of these protocols? Well, you may notice that
the first two terms here I didn't talk about.
I didn't talk about client login and I didn't
talk about AuthSub. Although these terms are
still pretty prevalent within our documentation,
you don't want to use these for new applications.
Really, in my personal opinion, you want to
use OAuth. You want to use the standards.
So client login is where you pass a username
and password and get access to the resources.
For obvious reasons, you as an application
don't want the liability of having a user's
username and password. AuthSub was the kind
of precursor at Google, the non-standard version
of something like OAuth. So you want to use
OAuth and then there's the different flavors
that you can use; 3-Legged OAuth is where
you redirect the user and the browser and
ask for access to their data. You use that
one when the individual user owns the data,
2-Legged OAuth is when you want to access
data for an entire organization, for entire
Google Apps domain and the Google Use case.
OpenID is when you want to access a user's
identity and then, you'll note that there's
a special version of OpenID for Google Apps.
And then lastly, there's the OpenID and OAuth
Hybrid that allows you to combine these things
together and do it all in one step. So now,
I want to kind of take all of this information
that you've learned and talk about an integrated
application and how it evolved. So this is
the SaaSy Payroll application that I was talking
about. The SaaSy Payroll application launched
a long time ago and just like every other
application on the Web, it had email addresses
and passwords. For every user within the system,
it stored both those email addresses and passwords
in a database table that looks like this.
So the bottom part of this screen here I'm
going to use to show what the database table
looks like. And here's a quick video showing
what that looks like from a user experience.
So the user says, "They don't have an account.
They're going to create one." They login,
they specify--sorry, they enter their email
address. They specify a password, a very short
one at that, they then get an email and they're
asked to confirm their account. They click
on that confirmation link and then they have
access to their payroll data. Now, that was
a very quick recording of the video but oftentimes
for many users, it takes a lot longer for
them to perform those steps. So the SaaSy
Payroll application, it wasn't integrated
with anything when it first launched. It was
just a payroll application. But then Google
in 2006 launched the Calendar API. The Calendar
API was the first of our Google Data APIs
based off of the Atom Publishing Protocol.
And then it allowed the SaaSy application
to add events to a user's calendar, to indicate
when that user was getting paid. So it's very
helpful if you have an upcoming mortgage payment
or car payment to know when you're getting
paid. So you want to be able to look at your
Google Calendar and have that information,
because Google Calendar launched their API,
SaaSy Payroll was able to offer that service
to their users. But the first version of the
authorization protocol that Google made available
for this was AuthSub. And AuthSub was its
propriety protocol but it looked much the
same as OAuth does today to the user. So the
user table on the database has increased a
little bit. In addition to having the email
address and the password for the user, it
also has a token for the user. That token
represents the applications access to the
protective resource, the application's access
to Google Calendar. So let's see what that
looks like. So here--on--below my payroll
dates, I have a link that says, "Add dates
to your Google Calendar." And the video is
freezing here a little bit but I'll pull you
up, then we'll continue. So I clicked "Add
Dates" to your Google Calendar. Then, I'm
asked to grant access to my Google Calendar,
just as you saw with OAuth earlier. I grant
access, the application now says that dates
are being added to my calendar. So I go into
my Google Calendar and I can actually see
that the paydays have been added to my calendar.
So you can see from May 15th and all the other
days of the month. Here, the paydays were
added. It's very useful for me as a user to
know when I get paid. So I'm very much happier
with this application and we'll continue to
use this payroll application for my small
business. So then, the users kept on complaining,
"You've made it really easy for me to integrate
with my calendar but why do I need to create
another username and password every time I
access my payroll? Why do I need to keep logging
in?" And so, with launching OpenID in 2009,
Google made it easy for the SaaSy Payroll
application to actually log users in with
their existing Google accounts. So you can
see here now, this application database table
or the users' database table no longer needs
to have a password for the user instead it
just stores the OpenID. And this OpenID just
represents that user and it's validated with
Google. So if the user visits again, it gets
Google passes on or search the OpenID and
the application could look it up in the database
table just as it would look up a password.
And now, you can see how the experience has
improved by implementing OpenID in the SaaSy
Payroll application. So instead of entering
my username and password, I just type in my
email address here and click "Login." I click
"Allow" because I'm already actually logged
in. I've already typed my password to Google
and I'm instantly signed in. I no longer need
to provide a new password which oftentimes
won't be a new password. And I no longer need
to deal with any of that email confirmation
because the SaaSy Payroll application is trusting
OpenID. And then the process of granting access
to calendar is just the same as it was before,
but there's two steps there, you know. So
then at the end of 2009, Google launched this
Hybrid OpenID and OAuth which we saw. And
what this meant is that they could do these
two steps in one. However, we're now using
OAuth for authorization, the standard instead
of using this AuthSub Propriety protocol.
It's a step forward for this application with
a little more code to write, but their database
table also has to store what different--what
the token types are that the application is
using. So you can see some of these tokens
were AuthSub tokens and then the third token
is an OAuth token and with OAuth, the results
of this seeker which we haven't done in too
much but it needs to restore that seeker.
And here's how that experience has improved
for the users. Okay at the end of the day
here as everyone getting on to the Internet,
maybe. Let's try--oh, there here we go. Okay.
So again, I type in my email address and I
hit Login. And then you can see it asks for
access to my email address and my Google Calendar
in one step. This just makes it a lot easier
for the user and makes it better for the application
because the application has gotten its new
users faster and thus we'll get more new users.
So it's created a one step. We're not going
to finish the video here because we're running
a little bit late on time. But the next step
here is Google launched the Google Apps Marketplace
earlier this year. Now like I said, this isn't
really a talk on Google Apps but it does show
an evolution in how OpenID and OAuth have
made things easier for users. With the Google
Apps Marketplace, an IT Administrator can
add an application like SaaSy Payroll for
all of the users within their organization
at once. That's why you see here three rows
were added to my database table. And none
of those rows have a token. They all stay
2-Legged OAuth and what that means is that
the SaaSy Payroll application can access all
of those users' data just by proving its identity
with its consumer key and seeker. It doesn't
need tokens granted by each of those users
because the administrator has granted access
to all of them in one process. So let's show
this and this is kind of the final video here
of how OpenID and OAuth have evolved for the
SaaSy Payroll application. Maybe. Come on,
this is the best one, all right. So we're
in the Apps Marketplace which is a store for
Web applications. I'm an IT Administrator
in this case and I'm signing in, I'm entering
my Google Apps Domain name and after entering
my Google Apps Domain name, I click Go, maybe,
all right, click Go. All right. We'll wait
a second here and see if this picks up otherwise
I'll just talk through it a little bit, but--all
right. So there's a very simple install process.
This simple install process first has to be
agreeing that I love the SaaSy Payroll application,
it's agreeing to the Terms of Service. Then
the next step is for granting that data access.
So here, when you see--the IT Administrator
is going to be granting access to the data
for the entire organization at once. So it's
saying, "It's okay for this application, the
SaaSy Payroll application to have access to
all of my users' Google Calendars." I'm going
to grant that access. I trust this application
and I use a non-SSL of URLs. So I'm also saying,
"I don't believe in believe in security at
one step." But we'll ignore that. You want
to use that as a cell for access in your APIs
even if some of the APIs work without it.
So then I hit Grant Data access
and enable the application. The SaaSy Payroll
service has now been installed for all of
my users and enabled. So users can go to their
email and go to what we call the universal
navigation bar which is that navigation at
the top left here.
And they can click on the SaaSy Payroll application.
I promise it really does work faster than
this in real life. One thing--click on the
SaaSy Payroll application, the users is actually
immediately signed in to SaaSy Payroll, because
the administrator had installed this application
and granted access for all the users in the
organization. The user doesn't need to okay,
passing its identity. The dates are also already
being added to Google Calendar. So every user
has their payroll dates on their calendar
even though they didn't inter--individually
interact with the SaaSy Payroll application.
I don't know about you but most people don't
visit the, you know, payroll application on
a daily basis so this is great. They're getting
access to when they're getting paid and that's
the information they need. So the future of
these protocols like I said it's really--it's
really kind a crazy in the standards bodies.
There's a lot of things being discussed. There's
a new version of OAuth that's in draft called
OAuth 2.0. It basically tries to make it a
lot easier for application developers by eliminating
a lot of the cryptographic signing of these
requests. That's the most complex part of
this. But there's not 100% agreement on it.
Actually, one of the primary authors of the
draft has a blog, it was basically saying,
"Making it easier isn't necessarily making
it more secure." And so I encourage you all
to read up on that. His blog is actually in
the resources section which I'll show here
shortly. So, OAuth 2.0 also does some things
around, making sure OAuth is compatible with
mobile devices and desktop applications and
that's all documented in the spec. You can
do some of that stuff with the previous version
of OAuth, but it wasn't explicitly documented.
There's another project underway called OpenID
Connect. And the idea behind this is why not
pass the identity information to an application
by building on top of the existing authorization
protocol. So building on top of OAuth 2 to
allow the user to grant access to passing
their identity, have one protocol instead
of two. You know, I'm very supportive of this
but we'll see how this--we'll see how this
works out in the standards committee. There's
a lot of active discussion, there's a lot
passionate people on this space. So here are
some resources. We have Technical docs on
OpenID and OAuth. There's the OAuth Playground
tool that I talked about. And then lastly,
there's the blog by one of the very prominent
authors of the OAuth spec with a lot of debate
on it. So I would encourage you all to read
that if you're really interested in these
protocols. Thank you very much.